Underwater splendor, thrilling action scenes,
and unbelievably human-looking animals. These
are the 12 moments in "Avatar: The Way of Water"
that showed us that James Cameron's still got it.
Since there isn't any human business to get out
of the way in "Avatar 2," we start by catching up
with the Sullys, who've been busy growing their
family. Jake, now fully and permanently Na'vi,
has gotten new dreadlocks and bulked up a
bit since he ran the military out of town.
He has two natural-born sons, a baby
girl, and an adopted daughter, Kiri,
who was born of Grace's Avatar. For a moment, the
film stops on shots of their faces in close-up,
particularly one of Neytiri that's perfectly
symmetrical. These early glimpses of the
Sully family's life, and especially these
detailed shots of their faces show just how
far the performance motion capture technology
Cameron uses has come in the last 13 years.
As impressive as the Na'vi were in "Avatar,"
they still appeared to have been somewhat copied
and pasted into backdrops at times, and their
movements weren't always entirely smooth and
believably real. The Na'vi in "Avatar: The Way
of Water" don't just look better integrated and
more realistic. They look hyper-real, almost as
if there is a reality out there in space that's
crisper, clearer, more colorful, and more
high-resolution than our own could ever be.
"Everything is backwards now. Like out there
is the true world and in here is the dream."
In the prologue, we learn that Jake, Neytiri,
and their brood have enjoyed years of
domestic contentment. During this time,
they've been lulled into blissful ignorance as
to whether the sky people might ever return – but
return they do. General Frances Ardmore fills
us in as to what's been happening on the human
end for the last decade. It turns out Earth
is officially dying, and she's been sent to
terraform Pandora to make it a suitable home
for the human race. Jake and Neytiri don't
know this yet. all they see are helicopters
and mechs burning down their beloved forests.
A deeply distraught Neytiri cries out as
she did at the end of the first "Avatar"
upon seeing history repeat itself.
Though what's happening is devastating,
the visual effects are astounding.
It's even more effective because
we don't expect an action set piece
on this scale so early in the movie.
When news broke that Stephen Lang had been
cast in "Avatar: The Way of Water," fans
justifiably wondered how that was possible. His
character, Colonel Miles Quaritch, died at the
point of Neytiri's arrow in that movie's climactic
battle. Lang is back, this time in the form of a
Recombinant — an Avatar spy without the need for a
human to control it. Quaritch's memories had been
uploaded as a type of consciousness into this blue
ten-foot-tall body. It sure seems like Quaritch
being resurrected as the thing he hates is setting
him up for a Darth Vader arc in future "Avatar"
installments, but for now, it's fun to watch
Quaritch prepare for his mission in the first act.
As the team is about to arrive on Pandora,
Quaritch the Recombinant is let out of a
pod-like chamber. He floats around in
zero gravity for a while before finding
a high-tech tablet-like device. A video diary
recorded before human Quaritch's death explains
to the reborn Quaritch who he is now, how
he came to be, and what he's meant to do.
"I know you're all asking yourselves
the same question. Why so blue?"
Over a decade after mating for life, Jake and
Neytiri still clearly have the hots for each
other. At one point, Jake narrates about how much
he looks forward to date night. For the Na'vi,
the height of romance is side-by-side
banshee flying just before the eclipse,
when Pandora's blacklight qualities
are at their most perceptible.
Jake and Neytiri each take their
bonded banshee out for a spin.
The sequel gives us about a minute of
our favorite blue lovebirds carefree
as they careen around the Hallelujah
Mountains and through Pandora's dense,
lit-up flora. It makes all the difference
that this isn't an escape or a mid-air melee.
"Avatar: The Way of Water" has more of everything,
including subplots. The one that dominates the
middle third of the movie is troublemaking son
Lo'ak's relationship with the outcast bull Tulkun,
Payakan. A subplot within this subplot
is the mystery of how Payakan lost one
of his fins. The first few times Lo'ak
and Payakan communicate, the whale-like
creature is reluctant to let the Na'vi boy
in on his secret. Eventually, Lo'ak earns
Payakan's trust, and it becomes necessary for
the supposedly killer Tulkun to tell the truth.
When the two bond, Lo'ak can see the
Tulkun's memories. The flashback is brief,
but the images of limp, dead Tulkuns
and Na'vi floating in flaming water
littered with ships and shrapnel affect
the audience as much as the young Na'vi.
Just like 2009's "Avatar," 2022's "Avatar: The
Way of Water" ends with a battle between the
Na'vi and the humans that's so monumental in
scale and length that it's hard to call it an
ending. The nearly hour-long sequence aboard
and around a commandeered RDA whaling vessel
is practically its own movie. Since it's
so involved, it's a fool's errand to pick
out a single frame or an isolated incident
that shocks and awes more than the others.
One of the better action set pieces within the
epic last act might have reminded viewers of
another iconic moment from James Cameron's
filmography — the sinking of the Titanic.
Jake is about to surrender to Quaritch to save
his kids, but the Pandoran whale gives him the
chance to attack instead. There are minutes upon
minutes of intensity that rival or surpass any
action movie of the last 10 years in the scenes
that follow, but the tension really ramps up
when everyone realizes the whaling vessel
is going to sink. Structures begin to break
apart. Water gushes into hallways. Characters
slide along surfaces and are sucked into vents.
As in "Titanic," the sinking ship in
"Avatar: The Way of Water" manages to feel
claustrophobic and like the most bombastic
action sequence ever at the same time.
Though "Avatar: The Way of Water" ends
with its longest and most complex battle,
it kicks off with one of the franchise's most
visually and narratively interesting conflicts to
date. After a short prologue, a title card tells
us that a year has gone by since RDA spaceships
reappeared in Pandora's skies. Jake, leader
of the Omaticaya, has been organizing guerilla
assaults every time General Ardmore's forces
breach their perimeter. This time, a high-speed
train with a cache of weapons and technology
is en route through Omaticaya territory.
The coordinated Na'vi attack begins as they
bomb the track, derail the supply train,
and loot the wreckage. This scene
wraps up as Jake's sons disobey him
and abandon their lookout positions
to join the warriors on the ground,
but before the family drama, there's plenty
of mesmerizing 3D-enhanced action. It feels
like Jake's insurgency is going to
explode right out of the screen.
"I am a warrior like you, i'm supposed to fight"
Lo'ak and Payakan are arguably the main characters
of "Avatar: The Way of Water," even though the
overarching plot revolves around Jake trying
to protect his family while he's unknowingly
pushing away his son. After Lo'ak picks a fight
with Tonowari and Ronal's kids, Jake makes them
apologize and tells them to play nice with the
people who've taken them in. Lo'ak tries, but the
Metkayina boys are pretty bigoted toward forest
dwellers. They lure Jake and Neytiri's second-born
son to what they insist is a good fishing spot
and, as a sick joke, all but leave him for dead.
The scene in which the boy tries to evade
Pandora's version of a shark is terrifying,
like something out of "Aliens" or "The
Abyss." A fade to black makes it seem
as though Lo'ak has drowned,
but he's rescued by Payakan.
The scene that follows, in which Lo'ak
helps to remove a harpoon from Payakan's
fin and forms a relationship with
the blue whale-sized creature,
is one of the most beautiful and emotional
in all of "Avatar: The Way of Water." The
use of light coming through the water, the
realism of every splash, and the difference
in size between these two "brothers" make
these fleeting peaceful moments stand out.
In a gripping but difficult-to-watch sequence,
Captain Mick pursues Ronal's soul sister,
who'd recently given birth to a calf.
After deploying a fleet of boats and
submarines armed with sound cannons, darts with
floatation devices, and exploding harpoons,
Ronal's Tulkun dies and her brain matter is
harvested as a human anti-aging substance.
The next hunt doesn't go as well for Captain
Mick. When a tracking dart lands in Payakan and
the Na'vi come to his rescue, the vengeful
Tulkun takes matters into his own fins. He
destroys the ship by wrapping the harpoon
cord around it and thrashing, resulting in
the aerial dismemberment of Captain Mick's arm.
These scenes aren't exactly beautiful, but they
are no less visually masterful than anything
else "Avatar: The Way of Water" has to offer.
The exotic, colorful forests of Pandora made
a lasting impression on fans of "Avatar." The
production design is probably the thing audiences
remember most (and most fondly) about the movie.
To keep things fresh, Cameron has added to
Pandora's worldbuilding with the Metkayina reef,
part of a tropical coastal system of Na'vi clans
far from Jake and Neytiri's corner of the moon.
As the Sully family approaches what
they hope will be their refuge,
they see misty mountains beset by tree roots
that extend into clear green-blue water. Na'vi
children play in rocky tide pools that resemble
Pandora versions of something humans might see
at Yellowstone. Three Brothers Rock protrudes
out of nowhere like monoliths from the Pacific
Northwest. The Metkayina are loosely based
on Indigenous cultures such as the Māori,
and production designers have brought
their world to life with texture and depth.
When seen in 3D, viewers might be
tempted to get out of their seats
and try to bounce around the Metkayina's
net bridges or take a bite out of their
crystalline fruit. Everything about the
reef makes one want to vacation there.
As "Avatar: The Way of Water" winds down,
it might feel like there's no possible way
for Cameron to top himself. By this point,
we've seen a train heist, a shark attack,
and a guy's arm getting ripped off by a magical
whale. We've seen more banshees than we can
count. We've watched Jake and his family learn to
bond and ride with Ilu, and we're no longer blown
away by scuffles between arrow-wielding Na'vi and
humans in mech suits. Then, for far too brief an
instant, Jake Sully and Miles Quaritch engage
each other in a fight above the reef waters.
What's exciting about Jake and Quaritch's
unfinished duel is that it's an earned
moment of rising action that's part of
what will be a trilogy-long conflict,
and it looks so much better than these
kinds of fantasy sky battles usually look.
Let's be honest, the "Avatar" movies are just
as much about allowing audiences to visit
Pandora as they are about telling a story.
So, when that story stops altogether after
the Metkayina decides to grant the Sullys
refuge so that everybody can just hang out,
it's not only fine, it's the best part of
the movie. For about the next half hour,
we learn to free dive with Tuk and Kiri. Sure, the
Sullys need to hone these skills if they're going
to live among the Metkayina, but this is really
an excuse for Cameron to show us what he can do.
"Just Breathe."
The underwater environments of "Avatar: The Way of
Water" and the scenes that take place in them look
so phenomenal they'll likely change filmmakers'
concept of what's possible with 3D storytelling.